you guys I might have found the absolute
best travel charger ever this is the
anchor mag Go wireless charging station
and this little thing can charge all of
my Apple devices simultaneously and then
it folds up into this tiny cute little
package so I can take it anywhere with
me it also has Apple watch fast charging
which is amazing because I won't need to
bring any additional cables I just bring
my USBC cable and it can power all of
this and charge all three things at the
same time I just love this design and
it's so small and compact this kind of
reminds me of something that would be an
official Apple accessory but it's not
it's from anchor and they make such
incredible products and this is never
leaving my travel bag again I guess it
will leave it sometimes when I take it
out to charge my items but you know what
I mean